hey guys so this is the webinar that
you've been waiting for
in this webinar were to talk about
extreme weight loss how to burn the most
fat despite having a slow metabolism so
it's taking me a long time to
consolidate and make this really really
simple for you so I'm gonna walk you
through a step-by-step exactly what to
do and you'd want to use this if you
have a slow metabolism if you're
plateaued it let's say you're going
through menopause or you have
hypothyroidism or you just want to lose
a lot of weight real quick if you
understand these principles you can lose
as much weight as you want it's a bit
extreme but it's also healthy so you
don't have to worry about anything
related to your health it's just a
little it's gonna take a little more
discipline so I'm gonna pull up my
powerpoint slides here we go right here
alright so that's just so good so let's
just dive right in okay I have a number
of slides we're gonna go through a very
a to be no fluff just you might want to
take notes okay so the first thing we're
talking about is carbs there's if you're
new to my channel we're gonna talk about
ketosis ketosis is basically fat burning
if you're trying to lose weight of
course you want to focus on burning your
fat right not burning your muscles or
just sugar fuel or just water weight we
want to actually burn fat the way to do
it is you must drop your carbs now in
ketosis the range of carbohydrates is
usually between 20 and 50 grams per day
okay
but we're going to do is we're going to
bring it down to as close to zero as
possible and what I'm gonna do as I go
through this presentation is just give
you the key things that you can do if
you want to implement so there's a lot
of different strategies you can combine
all of them are some of them but these
are the things that will help you lose
the most weight regardless of how slow
your
that was mints okay you may not need to
do this I mean as Extreme as I'm talking
about but at least you you can turn up
the dial as much as you want okay so we
want to get into deep ketosis that means
dropping our carbs as close to zero as
possible but maybe not zero because I'm
gonna recommend using lemon juice
there's like very small amount of carbs
and lemons but it does have some there's
a very small amount of carbs and eggs
it's not going to be a big deal maybe
some seeds maybe there's a little bit of
carbs and leafy vegetables but we want
to do this healthily because if you
don't add some vegetables it's gonna be
hard to get your minerals it's gonna be
hard to get your fiber to feed the
microbes so I'm building in all the
safeguards to make sure when you lose
the weight you do it healthily and you
look good as you're losing weight so you
don't look like a crackhead you know
you're looking all old and things so so
let's just kind of dive in of course
there's no limit to leafy greens of
course we're not going to recommend corn
peas beets carrots tomatoes squash but
if your metabolism is fast you can
easily add tomatoes and squash carrots
and beets and peas but not corn
I just don't recommend it because it's
normally always GMO so
just kind of just get walk you through
the most important things avocados are
totally fine I would avoid berries okay
avoid berries all right I just want to
touch on one thing and it's called
insulin resistance what's behind a slow
metabolism metabolism where whereby
you're trying to lose weight and then
you plateau and you cannot get below
that certain weight what's stopping you
is something called insulin resistance
you have a problem where your body's not
absorbing insulin that well and your
body makes too much of it so you have
too much insulin okay that's that's
really the problem and the presence of
that much insulin you're not going to
lose weight and so we want to do is we
want to correct insulin resistance
there's a couple ways dropping carbs is
one the other is feeding your microbes
in your gut you have about an hour 24 to
26 feet of intestines the last part
which is called the colon the large
intestine that has most of your microbes
probably like 95% of all the microbes
and that's where all the fermentation of
the fiber occurs and these microbes eat
fiber and the fiber we're gonna feed
them our vegetable fibers okay from
leafy green salads things like that now
that being said if you bloat with a lot
of vegetables of course kind of back I'm
assuming you're not gonna blow
I do recommend consuming a lot of
vegetables like between 7 and 10 cups to
achieve your nutrient levels okay some
people can't do that you have to work up
to it but I'm just gonna tell you one of
the reasons why to do that is to not
just for the deep potassium and
magnesium which will also lower insulin
resistance but the fiber feeds them
microbes and the microbes then give you
in exchange something really cool it's
called butyrate
what does butyrate butyrate is a natural
compound that not only feeds the colon
cells and give you gives you energy
but butyrate also majorly helps you
restore your int normal insulin levels
so it's very good for blood sugar
problem it's really good to correct
insulin resistance okay that is why
we're gonna do this okay so we got that
all right now protein okay I'm gonna
recommend moderate protein and that
means three to six ounces a protein per
meal
now with the ketogenic Plan the healthy
version I'm gonna recommend we always
have this confusion of protein and fat
what does it look like I'm gonna give
you a lot of examples so you can
visualize I think if you could see this
you can do it so I'm gonna actually show
you pictures in a second I'm gonna
recommend that you always consume most
of your felt with your protein together
in one food versus trying to add a lot
of extra fat with lean protein or
protein powder I don't recommend that
pounds and there's a couple reasons I'm
not going to get into it but it's just
healthy if you eat it that's one complex
and not do mean or low fat anything when
you go mean protein you spike insulin
more than the whole fat so the fat is
really really key so we want to do three
uh six ounces of protein per meal if
you're a big person okay you're gonna
need a little bit more maybe seven or
eight ounces if you're gonna start doing
in a minute fasting which we'll talk
about and you start doing less meals you
might need a little more protein as well
because that's your only meal of the day
okay so I'll show you as we get into it
the more protein that you consume now in
one meal the higher the insulin spike
and we're trying to keep insulin below a
lot of this protein that you eat we're
not a lot of it a good portion of it is
not used as calories as fuel it's used
to repair about a tissue so we're always
dealing with the ability to digest the
protein too and a quality source of
protein so salmon is a really good
quality fish other fish
eggs are really good grass-fed protein
is really good whey protein is not it's
very low on the list okay okay so we got
into that let's go on to the next one
salmon other fatty fish the best salmon
has omega-3 fatty acids one of the mega
3 fatty acids is called DHA it's really
good for the brain okay it's really good
to repair a damaged brain it's very
important in a growing baby but a good
portion of the brain is made out of DHA
so you're going to be very very safe if
you do foods with high amounts of those
omega-3 fatty acids compared to the
omega-6 fatty acids which is all the
seed oils and the vegetable oils like
the corn oils so soy oil that you get it
when you go out to eat or you know a lot
of recipes they have this vegetable oil
it's not very good it's very
inflammatory and it worsens the insulin
resistant situation DHA and omega-3
fatty acids improve the situation
sardines really good source of omega-3
hamburger do not get the extra lean
hammock or get the fattiest hamburger
you can eat that way you get your fat
with your protein it's going to create a
lot less spike on your insulin okay so
just to hammer this home lean protein
spikes insulin more than fatty protein
okay I know of some of you're saying
well what about the calories well we'll
get to that in a second
alright eggs make sure they're
pasture-raised eggs
okay organic eggs impossible versus like
pasteurized eggs you don't want to get
that you wanna get it pasture raised
like chickens that go out in the grass
okay I get my eggs at the farmers market
and from smaller farmers okay duck eggs
are awesome
awesome if you can get those it's the
yolks are huge very very good especially
for your liver by the way I personally
do four eggs a day I've been doing it
forever I'm not going to get into
cholesterol in this presentation you can
watch my other videos for that but
realize your body makes a good amount of
cholesterol like a lot so when you eat
more your body makes less okay
also cholesterol is needed for the
hormones cell membranes a lot of things
seafood very good very important for
trace minerals things like zinc selenium
these are minerals that will help with a
lot of different things but at the end
of the day we want you to consume foods
that supply all your nutrients okay and
trace minerals are a big one that's
usually missing some of you are not into
consuming pork that's totally fun you
don't have to I believe from just my
personal feeling is that if you have a
high quality pork product it's fine but
that's just my own viewpoint so I go to
the farmers market and I find out what
these pigs are eating and I am I don't
go to I don't buy my my bacon from
7-eleven okay where the or the
supermarket that you know the process
section I don't do that with the
nitrates and the sugars and all that but
the main thing is what they feed the
pork you know like they'll do GMO grains
we don't want to do that and if you if
you think pork is worse than chicken
I mean chicken is really really bad
unless it's fed non-gmo food so as
you're doing the beef in the pork and
the chicken whatever make sure you do
organic grass-fed would be better if you
do dairy make sure it's grass-fed
organic very important so avoid the whey
protein powder chicken
unless it's high-quality and also don't
but don't eat the chicken without the
skin you need that on I think the FATA
skinless chicken is like 13% which is
and there's a lot of problems with that
um I'm not gonna get into it in this
video but I will have another video on
them okay Turkey to lean protein powders
at this point I would recommend them
lean fish get the fatty fish lean meat
including hamburger is out so we don't
want to do that either alright so now
what to avoid in this program we're
gonna avoid nuts they do have some
hidden carbs and basically I'm giving
you all the things that you should do if
you have some sluggish miss with your
metabolism you want to speed things up
okay so if you if you don't have a crawl
with your metabolism you can do nuts but
I would cut them out if you're having a
hard time losing weight you'd be
surprised how much weight you can lose
by cutting out the nuts first of all
it's hard to digest okay plus they have
little more carbs and people are loading
up with nuts and they feel bloated and
it can definitely slow you down the
other thing too I mentioned dairy you
may want to just avoid all dairy at this
point what about some cream in your
coffee that's gonna be fine it's a very
small amount I mean if you have half and
half the amount of carbs you get is like
so tiny
if you better do your whole cream but
for the most part if you definitely
avoid yogurt milk kefir at this point
just because so many people have
inflammation from dairy some people some
people can't digest it it could be
constipating some of the dairy does have
carbs and just to speed things up we're
gonna avoid it
now I want to talk about fat but this
relates to protein because in nature
nothing ever comes exactly as fat
usually it's a combination of fat and
protein but I want to talk about this
when you do a keto plan they talked
about seventy to seventy-five percent of
your total calories being fat now what
the heck does that mean I mean I'm going
to show you a bit like a visual of that
but we're not even we're not even doing
72
five percent at this point and the
reason for that is that this is more of
an extreme version of the Kido that I
recommend in my book this is mainly for
people that have that need the x-factor
that need to go they need something
stronger because there's a plateau
they're plateaued and they're stuck okay
so if you go too high on your fat your
body will burn the fat calories possibly
more than your own fat okay that's not
what we're trying to do in the very
beginning I think it's very important to
increase fat to be able to go longer
without having to eat because we're
gonna implement and med fasting in a
second but but as you start adapting we
want to cut the fat down not til low fat
but to about 75 grams of fat or a little
bit less if you do that your body will
burn a lot more of its own fat if we go
too low on the fat you're gonna end up
with deficiencies and all sorts of other
problems we don't want to do that but I
want to just give you a total visual on
what this looks like okay so what does
75 grams of fat look like here's an
example right here 8 ounces of salmon ok
this is like oh this is like your
protein and fat for one day ok 8 ounces
of salmon we got 2 tablespoons of butter
maybe you use it to cook something Mac
nuts which again we're not recommending
to nuts but some people might be able to
get away with them out of all the nuts
to the macadamia nuts are the fattiest
so that would be a good thing and
they're also low on the oxalic level so
they're not going to actually aggravate
the many potential stone issues if you
are a stone former same thing with
pistachios but anyway this is what it
looks like right here ok here's another
example 8 strips of bacon and just so
you know what I eat in the morning or
actually don't need the morning my first
meal is like at 3 o'clock and I will
have my breakfast at 3 o'clock and I'll
have 4 eggs and I'll take one of those
packets of bacon and I'll normally kind
of
in half and I'll have half of that so
you might say wow that's a lot of bacon
it's actually a lot of fat cooks off and
it's not a tremendous amount of protein
I mean it's just it's it's something but
it's not like what you would think
so here's salmon I'm sorry the sardines
which is the high quality sources
omega-3 then make a coconut oil right
here and the brie cheese again for some
people
I wouldn't recommend the brie cheese but
I just want to show you what's 75 or 70
70 or 71 grams of fat looks like per day
just you can get it visualized visual
visual on this I'm gonna show you more
examples but I think it's important for
it just to kind of get an eyeball
because when you do keto like some
people say oh my gosh I'm just living on
pure grease and and it's all gonna be
just this huge chunk of fat no not
really
look at this 74 grams of fat 8 ounce
burger
brie cheese 1 tablespoon of olive oil
that you put that on your salad that's
not a lot of fat ok here's another one
we have tuna 4 ounces we got the bacon 8
strips got 2 1 1 egg olive oil 1
tablespoon little macadamia nuts it's
not that much here's another one
two tablespoons of butter we got 1/4
avocado and 8 ounce hamburger patty 35
grams so are you starting to see it's
like this is not terribly a lot of fat
but it's not low-fat either okay got
that here's another one
we got two salad dressing two
tablespoons personally I do olive oil
and vinaigrette the solvent on my salads
and then I put a little Parmesan cheese
okay so a town salmon and then we got
two MCT oil I'm gonna recommend that you
probably not do mc2 MCT oil on this
initially um unless your metabolism is
fine because even though it turns out
the ketones and you'll have a lot of
energy it might be a problem with you
tapping in your own fat however that
being said if you have a pre-existing
heart problem or a brain problem where
you have Alzheimer's or Parkinson's or
you have some type of a heart issue
NCT oil is awesome because it'll give
you give your brain more ketones to use
directly and it bypasses this insulin
resistance and it feeds the cell
directly and you get lots more energy
and you'll have a better output in your
heart you'll be less tired - okay
coconut oil look at that all right got
got that keep it simple just trying to
make this simple as possible okay now
getting a minute fasting intermittent
fasting is another tool but here's the
big rule do not eat unless you are a
hungry okay so many people are eating in
they're not hungry
if there's times you're not hungry don't
eat why because your body is eating your
own fat and as soon as you eat you're
gonna stop that process so we don't want
to do that we want you in fat-burning
24/7 okay so you started with three
meals a day
okay see this right here these spikes
insulin insulin insulin and then we have
we don't have any snacks we're adding
fat at the meal to be able to go longer
and longer now every time you eat you
trigger insulin so we want to keep want
to start working on cutting down the
frequency of eating over a graduate
period of time maybe two weeks okay but
if you start with three meals a day no
snacks and cut the carbs now your body
now it's gonna drop insulin and you're
not going to be as hungry so you can go
longer without eating so now you start
fasting okay so the ideal scene is to be
able to do this do three meals and then
you wake up in the morning and you ask
yourself am i hungry you go no don't eat
and you keep pushing you're your
breakfast further and further and
further and further until there is no
purchased and you get two meals lunch
and dinner okay you do that for a while
and then what you want to do with this
is you want to start pushing these
noodles closer and closer so eat later
because you're not hungry remember
you're you're going you're going and the
hungry eventually you're going to be
going till maybe one o'clock and you're
like well I'm not even hungry or maybe
even three o'clock I'm not even hungry
and then you'll be hungry then you'll
eat but let your body tell you when to
eat this is kind of a natural process of
adapting to your fat reserves an average
person who doesn't have a lot of extra
weight to lose as a hundred thousand
calories of fat sitting on their bodies
okay so but the ideal is to go step one
and step two which is worse squishing or
earth
eating window to a four hour window okay
so one to five let's see two three four
five yeah so four hours of eating right
here and then we got a 20 hour fasting
okay that's going to be huge but some of
you might already be doing this and
you're still not losing weight okay so
so you're going to ask them what do I do
well I'm showing you all the strategies
one step at a time and then if it's not
working for you but let's Eider you
don't have a gallbladder they took out
your thyroid to go through menopause you
died in your whole life you have no
metabolism and you're exercising six
hours a day and you're still not working
just stay tuned I'll show you what to do
okay so I already said this okay
the best clue that it's working is that
your hunger disappears okay if your
hunger is still there you still have an
insulin problem so as the hunger
disappears you know it's starting to
work
ride the way it go as long as possible
until you're at one meal a day
I have so many people right now that are
doing one in the day without any
probably feel great and they can lose a
lot of weight
most people some people can't I'm gonna
tell you what to do you're in that boat
but one meal a day gives you like 23
hours of fasting this is huge because 23
hours of fasting is going to give you an
amazing ability to repair and heal and
run your body on fat okay and you're
gonna feel good you can have more energy
but some people are not going to be able
to do now so what they're gonna have to
do is do one meal every other day now I
don't recommend jumping into this get to
one meal a day and then just ask
yourself am i hungry and the answer is
no then don't eat go another day without
eating
that will work for a lot of people that
just you what's happening with the with
people that can't lose weight even on
all mad which is one meal a day their
metabolism is wrecked I mean they did
something in the past you know screw
them up it could be severe insulin
resistance it could be some diabetes it
could be something when you do this
every other day eating you are going to
run you're not starving you're gonna run
off your stored fat a heck of a lot more
and that's when you're gonna start
seeing huge changes like huge changes do
I recommend it for everyone no but for
those people that need to do this it's
an option I want I want to give you
tools so you know have a backup strategy
if something doesn't work so this is
kind of a pie chart that I want you to
look at most keto plans have 70 or even
80 percent fat in this extreme plan it's
fifty five percent fat and it's thirty
nine percent protein so it's a little
bit it's adjusted okay so you're doing a
little more protein a little less fat
because we want we want to tap into it
if we increase the fat a little bit more
and decrease the protein what happens is
we we don't get the right ratios with
someone with the slow metabolism so this
is kind of a little kind of a hack of a
thing that I found that seems to work
notice that we have mandatory vegetables
in there to get okay with them with
fiber of course non starchy leafy greens
I've never met any person that had
slower weight loss by eating a salad
unless they had like some intestinal
bloating or something like that
which could be a situation notice that
the carb is 1% and I'm building that in
there because like maybe lemon water
which I recommend you take lemon juice
take the little juice like one ounce in
your water every day just to help you
with when you're in keto ketosis some
people potentially have more uric acid
and the lemon juice will count on that
some people develop more stones the
lemon juice will help help you with that
if your stone phone former that means
that you have a situation where it's
super concentrated urine and your
kidneys and that's where you develop the
stone one very simple guarantee to
prevent a stone will just be to consume
minimally 2 litres of water a day it's
not too bad 2 to 2 2 to 3 liters a day
of water and I recommend you exercise to
sweat as well but that fluid with some
apple cider vinegar with some lemon then
your kidneys will never have a super
concentrated fluid in there to velop
stones you'll prevent the stones okay
little tip all right so all right we got
the carbs low we got protein we got fat
vegetables okay we're not done yet we
have other tools that we can add
periodic prolonged fasting we talked
about intermittent fasting going one
meal a day and potentially one meal
every other day that's one strategy but
there's some other things you can do to
take it to the next level especially if
you have a let's see it Alzheimer's or
you have Parkinson's or you have some
type of autoimmune condition or or you
just want to pick up the pace this is
very very very powerful because periodic
prolonged fasting can create increased
stem cells you can grow new brain cells
you can drop information like you've
never seen before in your body so every
so often maybe once a month you do a 48
to 72 hours
once a month powerful powerful
it's very anti-cancer to tumors can't
live on ketones by the way all right and
then you come weekends to do a 48-hour
fast of course if you're doing ever the
other day you'll probably hit that right
here won't you but the point is you want
to do these periodic fast here in their
periodic prolonged fasting okay here are
some tips do it gradually because you
don't know your your mineral reserve you
don't know how many how much how many
vitamins that you're deficient in sub
clinically or more nutrients or minerals
so you want to go into this kind of
gradually so you don't like deplete
yourself this is why I recommend taking
electrolytes analysis B vitamins in C so
while you're doing this just to make
sure you know and then you're gonna be
fine there was a guy who fasted though
he took the record 384 days I think was
no food but he was medically supervised
but he took nutrients okay electrolytes
P vitamins sea salt so anyway do it
gradually add sea salts you need one one
teaspoon of sea salt per day count
average one teaspoon per day some of
this is going to be built in the food
but you need that okay you can even have
it to some water as well slowly not the
whole thing
also electrolytes I'm not biased and I'm
being sarcastic that I have the best
electrolytes out there but you might
want to try mine because it has a
thousand milligrams of potassium that's
it's in the form of citrate okay
which is really anti stone so it's going
to combine with any potential oxalates
that you get from spinach or any other
food that you're eating like almonds but
you're not doing almonds but the point
is that it can actually counter
potential stones
it also has magnesium citrate in it it
has calcium citrate and medicine
chlorides in there is a sea salt but
it's not big on sea salt so it's not
like a salt replacement you just have to
add so it's more ville
electrolytes and it also has trace
minerals in there so it's it's pretty
darn good no sugar no molten dextran
high quality stuff the B vitamins very
essential I recommend you get it from
nutritional yeast I do also have
something you could try itself it's in a
tablet I take them I chew them they're
kind of big tablets you can swallow them
to chew them but B vitamins are natural
get the one that's unfortified here's it
just a picture of mine you should only
use tablets non fortified but I did add
b12 and then this is the electrolytes I
have I have a a lemon raspberry flavor I
have a new one coming out which is
orange it's really good it's not I don't
think it's out yet it should you might
want to check by the time you're
watching this I don't know but there's
two different flavors and then I'll have
them in packs but you take one scoop
today and it gives you a lot of
potassium the minerals help with insulin
resistance as well here's another hack
rotating the times you eat okay
so let's say for example you have this
pattern and you're eating one meal a day
at 6 o'clock well let your body tell me
what need may be the next day you're
eating at night you're doing one meal a
day let's say at this point you're not
doing every other day let's say you do
three o'clock and then the next day you
do four o'clock next day and you seven
o'clock you can rotate that does have to
be at the same time if you rotate okay
and then you also stagger your prolonged
fasting so it's kind of irregular it
really will help you lose even more
weight because your body gets so used to
this thing that it starts to adapting
you could start getting used to its are
slowing down so you want to kind of
surprise your body same thing with the
exercise you switch up your powder and
every so often and it's called muscle
confusion apple cider vinegar very very
very very important to help with insulin
resistance it'll help to lower insulin
and what you do is you take a tablespoon
I take two tablespoons I put in a big
thing of water and I usually drink my
good portion my water and one but it
really will help you
add lemon in there it can be just lemon
juice or an actual imminent stress
reduction okay long walks on the days
that you don't work out are very good
for stress but I also have you can on
your own time watch I'll do a search of
dr. Burke stress webinar I actually walk
you through five different techniques
that you can do on yourself
or get someone to do it on you to drop
your stress level then help enhance your
sleep okay because it's all about
dropping course off but this is a good
video to watch on stress sleep if you
get more sleep
you have better insulin levels you have
better blood Sugar's you'd be less
hungry you'll lose more weight most the
fat is burned at night if you're not
sleeping that could be the big reason
why you're not losing weight I will say
though as you do this the requirement
for sleep goes down but it's very very
important to get enough sleep so I would
if I were you I would try to get eight
hours okay can you take a nap to help
that absolutely but the sleep is going
to be key the stress reduction
techniques I show you will help enhance
the sleep going for a long walks will
help doing help to sleep the
electrolytes will help to sleep the B
vitamins help to sleep so a lot of
things will kind of come together for
you there are certain sleep aids that I
have online if you need them but you
don't want to start taking melatonin and
that's one being one taste exercise okay
there's some tips with exercise I want
to talk about again we're just gonna
combine all these different really cool
things exercise is only responsible for
15% of your weight loss so it's not the
big thing but it does other things it'll
start to build if you do regular
periodic exercise over time it creates a
lot of oxidative stress but your body
adapts and it starts to build up a
network of antioxidants
your body actually makes any accents a
bigger bigger group that will actually
protect the damage that even when your
cells are making from the exercise so
that's one way to build up it's called
your antioxidant Network I did a video
on that recently and I think it's the
anti-aging video but exercise exercise
very very vital to just add to
everything I would highly recommend you
exercise in your fasting state when you
haven't eaten that will spike growth
hormone okay so that's one thing number
two the intensity exercise is what
spikes growth on them the more intense
the more growth hormone growth hormone
is the main fat burning hormone the
ideal best exercise to stimulate growth
I'm going to be sprinting sprinting is
very painful because it's like an
explosive thing but if you could do
seven cycles of a thirty second sprint
that would be hot you might not be up to
it that's fine do your bike do your
aerobic class spin bike let do something
that would be important you would spike
the most growth hormone okay let's say
you spike the most growth hormone to
seven seven hundred percent more when
you're sprinting that's huge
most people have to gradually ease into
this yeah okay so use a full body type
exercise like burpees and planks and
plyometrics jumping rope spinning versus
like just weights here's the thing when
you do fasting that can stimulate growth
hormone by 2,000 percent in men thirteen
hundred percent women so you can see
exercise is only seven seven hundred
percent but still we got a good
situation because we have this this
growth hormone that is into aging you
can start looking good as you losing
weight okay then we have interval
training which I recommend the magic
timeframe of doing interval trainings
between 20 and 40 minutes okay if you do
it longer you tend to lose your gains
because you overdo it and you over train
if you're over the age of 40 you
definitely need to do two times a week
maybe once a week and gradually go into
it my wife and I were on fifty-fifty we
got 54 she's 55 or 6 don't quote me but
here's the thing we work we we do
hardcore interval training twice a week
and on the other days I will work some
other muscles and things but I'll do
cardio I'll do the bike every other day
and so I'm doing hills or things like
that but it takes a while for your body
recover its best it's best when you work
out to get to the point where you're
doing it enough so you're sore then wait
you fully recover then to do some
exercise and you're trying to you're
kind of halfway going through it you're
not sore and you're doing that more
frequently you're not gonna see the
gains when I get sore okay so you have
to increase the intensity or maybe even
the volume okay guys I just gave you a
tremendous amount of summarized
information it might it might seem
simple but it took me a long time to
kind of make it simple I have this
entire program in a document that you
can download
it's called t2 on steroids chichi chichi
and it's an updated version from my
original one and I do charge for it it's
very very expensive it's a dollar and
the reason I do this because I just
don't want to give every single thing
away for free I want you to at least
invest something so you'll actually if
you invest in something you'll actually
I found you'll take advantage of it more
you'll implement it more than if
everything is just giving tree so it
does cost a dollar you can go to dr.
brew calm and it's just keno - on -
steroids okay so it's dr. burr comport
slash key tip - on - terror is it should
be linked down below you can get the
summary sheet download it follow it get
all the details implement it it won't
work and I'm telling you everything that
I've tried over the years after I've
been approached 29 years I personally
worked one
with over 40,000 people and I tried so
many different things this is the thing
that is the most powerful that you
should focus on the most now you have
the ability if you can go through this
to turn up the dial as much as you want
or down as low as you want because this
is strict this is extreme this is
hardcore so you might not be there with
your discipline but you might be like
really really good within a minute
fasting but you're not perfect with the
carbs okay good well then do more and
more fasting or let's say you're not
really good at dinner fasting but you're
good with the cars or let's say you're
not good with UNAMID fasting nor the
carbs then you're gonna need to go
really quality food at least you're
getting good quality food right so
anyway I gave you a lot of parts of the
parts of this puzzle now it's up to you
to get started get started and please
give me your success story as well thank
you so much for attending this webinar
and I hope you enjoyed it and comment
below if you did enjoy it thank you